hello babies episode 54 of
congratulations is brought to you by the
cash app you want to get paid $5 and
also give $5 to charity then now's your
chance to do so right now if you
download the cash app and enter the
reward code Congrats
you'll receive five dollars in the cash
app will send $5 to the times up Legal
Defense Fund and that's important to us
here at congratulations
to me and one fire so cash up isn't
immoral finance in the App Store and if
you're not if you're not with that then
get with that
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now start man it's supposed to
start the timer and let me know when I'm
supposed to come in after the theme song
and I have a whole screen on on my wall
that you guys can't see that I'm looking
at and it has the timer on it and it's
got he's got a bunch of other stuff open
and he put the other stuff over the
timer so I wasn't able to see when I was
supposed to come in so I don't know if I
came in too early or too late either way
you know what the deal is on fire and by
the way it spelled one fire like the
like the [__] name one and then FY re
it is not spelled W a n and some people
write it that way and then now that's
very [__] stupid and now let me
explain why because one is not a name OS
is a Chinese guy and it's not Chinese
guy he's a Mexican guy one fire is
Mexican now even though he's not Mexican
he's white guy and even though you don't
know his true identity Juan fire the
producer in essence as the Mexican guy
that's where his name's Juan
so anyway this is episode number 50
something so that's great I was driving
down to get my coffee or
and while I was doing it there was a
traffic jam on the on the street on my
Street which is really my street is
really [__] annoying for that [__]
because it just is too small and it's an
I'm in the hills and [__]
and this guy was like not moving on the
street and then he moved and then and
then and then people were trying to come
up and I was behind him and he was in a
car and I was like all right I was like
he's not moving all right I'm gonna go
in front of him so I went to go move
around in front of him and he [__] go
he leans out of his window he says what
the [__] you think I'm doing that I'm
just here for my health and now I went
from zero he went from zero to 60 in the
anger Department and so I went to 70 in
the anger Department because what the
[__] and I said yo man what the [__] I
don't know what the [__] you're doing
there's crazy people out there maybe
you're just sitting there for no reason
I said maybe you're just maybe you're
[__] waiting for somebody in the
house what the [__] do I know
you [__] [__] and I call him a
[__] [__] and then he was like he
was like oh think about it don't be
stupid and I was like there's a hundred
percent chance of a [__] possibility
that you could absolutely be waiting for
somebody to come out of their house and
I was right you know I was just right
and he felt real dumb I'm sure oh so
then he went ahead of me which he was
ahead of me anyway and then got down and
there's a shortcut I know about and he
doesn't know about it
because he says no [__] because he's a
[__] brain-dead [__] dumb [__] I
saw him and his argument made in a sense
so I I went and I blasted through the
shortcut and I got in front of and I and
there's and there was a when when it
intersects back at the when it
intersects back to the front you meet
each other again and I was ahead of them
and I was ahead of him this time
so I Al Unser jr. did and I [__] saw
him and then I rolled down my window and
I go like this
I stuck my tongue out and [__] gave
him the finger dude I bet that bunched
him up [__] oh I bet that
bunched him up oh I bet that [__]
bunched him up dude
don't [__] yell at me on my street
you [__] [__] i [__] murdered
that fool dude you know what I did i
[__] trip I took a traffic I I
slammed them in a traffic by traffic
slammed them yo dude I'm to park when I
Drive man you don't [__] you're on my
street you are my Street [__]
yeah dude you're on my street and you're
gonna tell me how to drive bro and I'm
not wrong here oh dude [__] my Dennis
Franz don't turn me into Dennis Franz
baby don't turn me into Dennis Franz in
the NYPD blue every time I turn into
NYPD blue
then it's Franz is yelling somebody and
it's always on the audience Channel so
uh speaking of slamming though I did the
Grand Slam this week I [__] had the
bases loaded and Daddy just knocked one
out of the park
I [__] slammed the ball so hard that
I hit it and then I just relaxed my body
and then I said very softly to nobody
while I'm on the diamond say good night
Gracie
so what I said I said say good night
I did the ultimate slam the grand slam
Denny's thinks that they have the Grand
Slam but they don't you know who was the
Grand Slam daddy on Friday night that's
who I had the Grand Slam and I'll tell
you about it and if you follow me on my
Instagram you already know about it but
this is what happened and I'll tell it
into in more detail first of all let me
start by saying I don't like pranks I
don't think they're very funny I think
that mostly if somebody's doing pranks
they're not funny they just
it's what to me it's always what people
who aren't that funny think are funny
are like pranks to like like pulling
down someone's pants in public that's
not funny to me it's just like you saw
somebody do it so you know that
something so you can do it now
he got B cat right
in essence yokota but this was something
that I guess technically would be
classified as a prank
and I can't I can't I I couldn't resist
this because it was just too good all
right so my opener Mike by the way how
do I turn these two headphones up top
left I got it yeah all right cool worked
one fire one higher but one fire cause
was too long the first night anyway
so here's the deal so so my opener Mike
Leno Qi he [__] I bring him around in
the country and [__] and he opens for me
most of the time I have a lot of openers
to but are you some allowed so so he he
like buys clothes from Old Navy and [__]
and he'll get you know like dude who the
[__] buying clothes from Old Navy by
the way who's buying that [__]
oh maybe by the way I wouldn't buy
clothes from Old Navy
Old Navy Ossa Mexican Old Navy because
because of the guy on the thing I hate
that [__] oh maybe I hate that so much
dude Old Navy in their quirky ass
commercials oh maybe we've got pans for
four dollars there's [__] in them anyway
like go to H&M it's cheap it's just as
cheap and it's way better and also
they're completely racist anyway so
so I saw my opener said he has bad
clothes do it he wears like swag and
[__] that or I guess schwag you call it
I don't what the [__] they call it [__]
that you get for free and [__] anyway
and we're like a shirt from a podcast
and you're like what was a [__] you
doing so and like basketball shorts I
had what [__] don't 33
you were basketball shorts out so so he
said to me he was like he got some money
cuz he was making some money and I was
opening up for me and he's [__]
making some money and he was like I'm
gonna [__] finally buy an outfit that
Chris it thinks would it would be cool
and I'm gonna buy an outfit that I know
it's good because G starch you know how
it plays like g star and diesel and [__]
like that and and they're good they're
good they got good [__] so he got this
outfit from G star I guess and he got
this sweater and these pants and all
week he was sending it to the group text
the group chain like hey dude it's over
[__] I finally got some good
clothes I got these pants and this shirt
and he was taking video of his shirt and
his pants and sent it in to me and and
and our other other friends and some
other openers and [__] dude you're not
gonna be able to follow me dude the
student finally surpassed the teacher
and he was like now I got a good outfit
and it's give me the confidence I'm
gonna [__] go on stage on Friday
night and I'm gonna kill and you're not
gonna be able to follow me and I'm like
alright well okay you know fine I mean
you know let him live in his [__]
world and it's fun and it's cute and I
know he's also not being serious
so he so Thursday night before the show
on Friday night at the Laugh Factory I
get this idea oh I can ruin this guy's
night I can go on Friday because I know
exactly what outfit he got I can go by
the exact same outfit show up at the
show be wearing the outfit and the best
part about it is nobody is going to
think that I'm dressing like him because
he's the opener they're gonna all think
that he's dressing like me not to
mention I go onstage after
so I can just say oh this [__] guy is
now dressing like the [__] guy he
idolizes how [__] dumb is this guy
that he goes and he tells me oh and he's
bragging like aw yeah you're not gonna
be able to follow me dude I went to
g-star and I bought by the way I showed
up and the [__] outfit was on the
mannequin what a [__] do you not I
mean how far you know when I saw it on
the [__] it when I saw the outfit on
the mannequin
I just about [__] myself I was like this
guy bought it first straight from the
mannequin what a sucker you know dude
you're a [__] sucker if you see
this [__] you know how embarrassing it
is to cuz people know that some people
saw the [__] and then we'll see you in
the be like oh that's the [__] II saw
it on the mannequin looks better without
a head so I show up with the outfit and
the reactionist prices he's got a great
reaction
you gotta look it up on on my Instagram
and then and then I go on stage and I'm
like dude how [__] [__] is it that
he's where he's dressing like the guy he
works for now he's [__] this [__] has
dressed dressed like me and and it was
great man he came up on stage and he was
like told him the truth with like such
like it's a [__] look at his face bro
you know my openers face dude sometimes
he just [__] face you know anyway
dude it was awesome
it was a [__] 100% Grand Slam took
the wind out from him and from under his
sail under his sails under his wings
whatever the [__] I don't know anyway it
was so funny so check it out on my
Instagram so that's it
I murdered him on the great Agron
slammed it I I [__] I love [__] like
that man I love making fun of people
that you love that then it like you you
do that [__] and that brings it together
now I don't know I've it's been a while
since I've been on the other
out of it though you know like I get it
I wonder I was growing up all I was
always the [__] blood of this [__]
like dude I think I think honestly in my
family I was the one who got made fun of
the most like my mom my brother my dad
like a hundred percent and I think that
that's why I love it so much because
they love me so much
and if I'm making fun of you it's kind
of how I show that I at least like like
you or want you to be a part of the
group you know so I love doing it I love
doing it to people that I love and I
like doing it to even people that I like
right like if I like some people I like
right away and I just start busting
their balls and I like it when they do
it back it's fun I don't know I love
being made fun of it I love making fun
of people I don't get it when people
just don't like it light and they're
just like get offended and [__] I mean I
understand not everybody's upbringing
was the same but some of these
[__] were just item wins it is
when somebody gets bent out of shape
because of some [__] that you're making
fun of and you're just [__] with them
like they just that's a rough childhood
they must have had that's just a rough
childhood they must have had I don't
know it's psyche there's two things
though that if you make fun of a guy for
a man for it'll [__] him up
and one is their outfit but the other
one that's the main one that's the home
one that always works the outfit kind of
works what always works is their haircut
or their hair does it God what's up with
your hair if you just say that the guy's
nights [__] what's up with you what's
up with your hair and they say oh what
do you mean is your own no nothing I
just nothing you'll [__] them up all
night or if you just talk to them and
you kind of like look at their hairline
while you're talking uh yeah and just
keep looking up okay yeah your cocoa oh
okay and then kind of let's tear it and
then go like this huh and then walk away
you'll [__] him up for a week that's
[__] psychological warfare dude
what's up with that what's up with the
chicks just shaving their head and be
and being brave it's up with that what's
up with
chicks just being like I'm gonna shave
my head now brave what are you doing
what's going on what's really going on
huh
hey your guard question for you what's
really going on I don't need to
subscribe to before you even say
anything what's really going on nobody
because I just think that the the way
the world perceives you oh stop right
there besides that before I even get
started
scone Han it's really going on you had a
rough get a rough go huh
get a rough go you don't need hair to be
beautiful okay cool why are you shaving
it though
you tired that's the [__] I do it for me
everyone when people say I'll work out
for me
ah [__] suck my dick though really ah
really
turn around oh you work out for you yeah
there's no vain [__] involved you don't
like your abs oh yeah you do that for
you real quick step out to dunk hey let
me assure you outside for a sec good
dunk okay whoops you're lyin whoops
you work out for you I have one small
thing to say whoops did you slip and
fall
cuz whoops you lying dude you don't have
to yeah but what's really going on how
come everybody [__] it's like people
get on their high horses it's so on it's
so unreal remember that no hate [__]
with the tape over their mouths I
understand no hate and don't have hate
hate is bad but take that [__] tape
out of your mouth off your mouth yeah
nobody's silencing you this is that you
can say anything this is the oh but
we're not allowed to yeah you are yeah
are you can say whatever you want now
more than ever anybody can say whatever
they want and get it out there so take
that [__] tape off me mount and
instead of putting the tape on your
mouth let me assure you outside a sack
dunk
dude that no hate [__] I mean I
understand it I understand no hate I get
it and I'm not knocking that but these
[__] you know and it was a successful
campaign sure I mean but are we really
not hating are we hating less nah we
hating more ya know how I know this is
the president hates everyone and he's
the number one leader of the free world
hey I mean so many people did these
[__] but the tape over there Mouse
and then a picture like this what why is
it a beauty shot dude why is it a beauty
shot oh look who did one who's this guy
who's that guy what's that guy's name
again Nash Grier he did one remember
what he called everyone the [__] gay
gay guys he caught him the f-word
remember what he said that rhymes with
maggots remember when he said that no
hate
except when I'm on vine though no hate
my ass dude
that's what people [__] it that's
what people hate double talk
[__] guys wearing some [__]
uh Eyes Wide Shut masks you know who
they are
remember that [__]
what shuts that [__] dude eyes wide shut
one of my favorite movies of all time
period top-10 period
ding-ding-ding-ding ding-ding-ding-ding
ding-ding-ding-ding the whole movie you
know the balls to have to have [__]
two piano notes playing the whole movie
ding-ding-ding just look up any YouTube
video on it Tom Cruise and Nicole Kidman
that movies the rocks dude and then they
put on the [__] masks with the dick
nose and go look at everybody [__]
dude I want to do one of those ding ding
ding I want to do one of those I want to
go to one of those places where you wear
a mask and watch everyone [__] and
have everybody like watching you Muslim
I'm Jim Jim and Jim Lovell all named um
Jim loud nominees um dumb dude if
there's more than five people [__] in
a room there has to be that music
playing solemn lomi lomi human the imam
lammle ain't no nom nom didn't till I'm
there I'm a dumb dumb dumb long long
long long and even if it's not a [__]
what do they call him a didgeridoo
you just have some big [__] fat guy
just in the corner at me magician lemma
nom nom nom nom it with a big mask and a
dick nose
you know I'm just jerking off in the
corner watching go ding ding ding ding
ding ding names Rome Rome their mammal
Amish anomaly anomaly I'm them them them
them them them name name name name name
sham lamb lamb lamb dude that movie is
[__] so dope
that's one of my favorite movies of all
time Tom Cruise is
[__] oh man I made I love that movie
dude I'm watching a little bit of a Tom
Cruise just Christ so hard at the end of
that movie for no reason finding a mask
submit I found a mask he subscribe me
bling bling thing give me Mom leave me
me me me me me me me me him I want to go
to one of those [__] dude some chick
asked me to go to one of those once she
was like yeah let's go let's go you you
wear a mask and and everyone [__] and
you watch everyone [__]
and I'm like no nah she was like why not
I said cuz everyone's gonna know it's me
she said no you wear a mask I said you
can still tell I look like a [__]
bird oh no but you were a mask with it
[__] beak on it oh cool they'll know
more cuz I look more like a bird no put
these wings on people give me like
that's Chris D'Elia
she's like other celebrities go oh yeah
cool let them go
there's no way if I went and I put a
[__] beak nose dick [__] face mask
on and then went on to one of those
things there's no way she's like
pictures aren't allowed yeah see yeah
she's like come on go we'll [__]
everyone I was like nah hey men you
derelict come on dude
nah not going to one of those [__]
big nose [__] parties just give me the
mask and I'll [__] I want to go home
and [__] someone in it give me the mask
I'll go [__] you know my girlf my loving
wife within it that would be that is
amazing dude dude I want to know how
weird [__] some married couples like
sex lives are you know like that [__]
like I people you know how like guys are
like you know how like some guys I don't
know if everybody knows this but some
guys like if you show your dick to some
guys like come on man like you got one
you have one you're [__] dumb [__] oh
I don't need to be seen all that [__]
that if a guy shows me his dick I
[__] stare at it dude what are you
gonna do man I'll spit at it you miss
aluminum I'll put on my dick nap mask
dude like it's a dick bro I'm Greek as
[__] when it comes to that [__] I'm
Grecian I'm the guy when they would put
the lily pad over their dicks I'm the
guy that goes like this well this is
four and I throw it in a [__] hot
spring we doing it are we doing it you
don't [__] half-ass Greek [__] we're
all Grecian baby show your dick show
your dick I get why girls don't want to
show their butt dudes if you're around
dudes I went to a rush Russian was it
Russian no it was an Asian bathhouse
once and I was with my jujitsu class and
we all went there and this big-ass
Russian guy named Alexi of course came
out dick swinging dude everyone had
their towels on and he was just like hey
how's he going and gave me a hug I was
like rubber rubber bro doesn't that
heavy dick touch me
but yeah so III I don't I would go to
one of those [__] parties but I
wouldn't want to [__] anyone that would
be so weird to me I just want to go see
it but they don't want people to just go
see it you know although they probably
do have some casual observers because
that's probably a kink for some of them
you know but I would want to go with
like a [__] mask on of another actor
that might be there
like if they made our [__] Harvey
Keitel mask you know and then show up in
Harvey Keitel's they're [__] someone
with a beet nose mask and you just and
you look at him and you're like hey
what's up that would freak him out
you'd probably have an orgasm
immediately be like kiha name is Roman
Mahna Mahna mean he's the guy Harvey
Keitel's the guy in the corners gone me
and Michelle omnomnom you show up with a
Harvey Keitel mask or show up dressed
like up within a vote for Pedro shirt
with suspenders like Napoleon Dynamite
and John what's-his-name John hey
whatever his name is on the Napoleon
Dynamite he was uh Johnny header yeah
John header right and he's there he's
just like gosh
come on gosh um you're really funny
Swede I show up when my vote for Pedro
mask what he's [__] um yeah but ah man
how funny would be if I went to that
party and then like somebody took a
picture though for real and then tweeted
it and then like they were like Christa
Lea goes to sex party just to watch I
would [__] own that [__] though I hid
out all these [__] like all these
politicians and [__] when they get
caught they're like I'm so sorry no
you're not dude don't be sorry just
[__] be like you know what dude you
know what I always dreamed of a
politician getting caught and I'm not
even saying that this is right but like
getting caught [__] around with like
hookers and evident be like not and hold
a press conference and show up and be
like all right listen you know I know a
lot of people I know a lot of people
come up here and politicians you know
when they're getting some hot water they
come up and they apologize to everybody
I just want everybody to know that and I
want him to look in the camera and be
like I'm a hundred percent not sorry
honestly I like [__] hookers and I
they like what they do they make money
and that's what's up
and I'm gonna keep doing it probably I
don't wanna come up here and tell you
I'm not gonna do it anymore that's kind
of my thing I like having sex I'm a guy
and I think that we're not going to get
anywhere as a society unless somebody
comes up here and owns who they are so
that's what I do
vote for me and then he walks a maybe
like you're probably gonna impeach me
say yeah I know I know he'll be a but if
it was me I'd be like I know I know
gonca gonna turn around turn around step
out I get it all right look I get it
good gon come makuta but look it's Who I
am
why why I look at get it where's my nose
face in the differ eyes my nose face in
you know you know I get it but I give
him money I think I wanna make go
shopping and they like it do you know
how much respect I would have for some
[__] guy that did that that guy would
have my vote for the rest of time I
don't give a [__] if all of a sudden he
was like you know what [__] everyone
who's 6 2 and white with long hair
I'd be like doesn't matter he said the
thing vote for him uh I want to hear
about it if you ever been in one of
those sex parties I'm talking about with
the cloak though and the dick nose I'm
not talking about oh yeah I was at my
buddy's house we all started [__] now
I'm talking about you showed up there
was an invitation you took like a Rolls
Royce or some [__] it was in a big house
you never been in was with so much Brown
in it and would [__] curvy furniture
that looks so uncomfortable BAE a
chandeliers anyway
if you've been to a [__] party let me
know if you've been to a fancy [__]
party the cash up is the number one
finance app in the App Store probably
because all of the babies have been
switching and we're a cult and we are
making it the number one cash app and if
you haven't you code it so let's get on
board it's the best pizza maybe it's
because it's the best way to pay people
back though in all honesty friends
family co-workers everyone
truckers sending and receiving money is
totally free and fast and most payments
can be deposited directly to your bank
account in seconds Square cash is cool
because it doesn't have the feed you
don't get people don't know if you're
paying someone back for sushi or
something I don't want that I'm more of
a private guy that's why I would wear a
mask at one of those parties the new
cash card is a black debit card that you
can design yourself via the app the cash
card allows you to use the cash that you
keep in the app anywhere you want you
get notifications for all payments made
with the card directly via the cash app
your laser at your card to personalize
it the artistic get this and you can put
whatever you want on it and it ships to
you directly for free right now if you
download the cash app and you enter the
reward code congrats you'll receive five
dollars and the cash app will send five
dollars to the times up Legal Defense
Fund you want to get paid five dollars
and also give five dollars to charity
your good person download the free cash
app for iOS or Android now now I want to
talk to you a little bit about something
maybe you saw the Instagram video I
posted where I was saying you touch the
top of T bottom lip or no it wasn't that
one it was the one where I say shut the
[__] up that I was wearing a sweater
with this company on it called tripping
now it's called tripping now does that
sound white as hell yeah it does
tripping babies but did you know that
the average family visits five totally
different websites before booking a
vacation rental look I love traveling I
love doing it I love I love going to
different cities I love seeing how
everyone does it
I you know I went to tamp I had a great
time
and I usually have a great time I make
the most of it okay with tripping you
can spend less time planning your next
trip and more time relaxing with
tripping calm the world's number one
site for
vacation rentals trippin comm is trusted
by millions of travelers and featured by
the New York Times Travel and Leisure
Forbes and more whether you're looking
for a cabin log cabin or a beachfront
home to get away this winter or already
looking ahead to vacations this spring
or summer trippin comm can help you find
the perfect place to stay
vacation rentals offer flexibility perks
and amenities that hotels don't like
multiple bedrooms backyards hot tubs
free Wi-Fi and even fully stocked
kitchen so you can plan and cook your
own meals it's great for families and
large groups it's great with tripping
calm onesearch lets you filter compare
and sort over 10 million available
properties on trusted sites like verbo
TripAdvisor booking.com
and more don't wonder if you're getting
the best deal you'll save an average of
18% per night by booking your vacation
with trippin comm you like to save don't
you or are you an alien so don't forget
if you want to save time and money while
booking the perfect vacation rental for
your next trip ahead go to trippin comm
/ Congrats today that's T RI PP ing comm
/ Congrats trippin comm / Congrats now I
spelled it for you in case you're a
[__] idiot
everyone knows how tripping is spelled
unless you're 5 but if you're 5 don't
listen to this podcast because I say
[__] a lot and talk about sex parties
ding ding ding ding I also talk about
eating children's thighs sometimes YUM
not me I don't do it I just referred to
somebody who did do it once YUM dude I
got so much love for that [__]
segment I did I actually didn't think it
was gonna go over that well I thought it
was too much YUM
but man people have been tweeting me YUM
so much from the last episode the thighs
are the best part YUM I mean come on do
it
the best part are the thighs and lips
iam I would love to eat a children yum I
love eating children YUM smiley face YUM
anyway
throwback to a week ago for you guys I
[__] forgot what I was gonna say man
and I don't remember now and I'm pissed
off pissed off oh yeah oh you know what
I was watching this guy on I can't
remember how I said I saw one of the
funny guys tweeted this video about this
guy who's like this greaser what's he
called the man man gree man something
man something like not man hunter but
something like that but like he's a
greaser he's not on Twitter he's like a
he's got a YouTube channel anyway he's
this Greece when he's talking about how
the greaser lifestyle mmm it's really
funny somebody guys probably what I'm
talking about I don't know if he has
that many that many followers but anyway
he's talking about I was thinking about
this and then I saw this guy's videos
and then it kind of solidified it and
that's not that guy he's talking about
like how he hates posers that pretend
like they're greasers when they don't
really know about the Greece life Greece
or lifestyle but he's also talking about
how it has to be okay for somebody to
start being a greaser and you can't make
fun of somebody who's trying because
they will eventually become the greaser
greaser and they have to be given the
leave way the leeway to practice and
become one so you're not a poet but then
he's talking about how you're a poser if
you do that but then also that's him
what is his name I mean
get into a name cryptic art I don't know
maybe that's another account but anyway
now I'm on fire
Google cryptic art of course a bunch of
cryptic art showed up now that's very
stupid and that's why these names one
fire okay type obviously greaser cryptic
art and it still doesn't come on fire
even deeper anyway this guy is hilarious
so I've started thinking about how you
you literally like people who talk about
how they hate this they hate that yeah
that's him I mean look at this guy he
talks about how he's like you know
martial arts and now you
I mean the guys are [__] great
character study but the people who I
wrote it down and then I saw this
[__] [__] but like people who think
they're not away we'll talk about how
they hate somebody is that way but
they're really talking about themselves
as projection right like that's the most
amazing thing I think to me it's the
most amazing thing that'd be like I'll
dude I hate posers who [__] think
they're greasers and then you're you're
that it's so funny to like project that
and have and have it be like like I
don't want people to think that about me
and I hate that but I'm the real deal
like that's a sad sad
I don't know there's something else I
there's something else I wanted to
pertain to it and I wrote this and I
wrote this on that note so I don't even
know what it means
everyone wants what they say they don't
want again maybe it's just basically
[__] III you know when you [__]
talking about something
or you think about something and you
have a feeling that goes with that
thought
and you're like oh I feel a certain this
thought makes me feel this certain way
right and then a week later you'll think
of the thought and it won't give you
that feeling and then you're like it's
just a thought you don't have the
[__] passion or feeling behind it I
[__] hate that dude I bet someone you
know what I'm talking about right I hate
that I want to always have the feeling
that's associated with the thought
otherwise I feel like a goddamn robot
YUM and I'm not a robot I'm a human
human being um so I don't know what the
[__] I was feeling when I said that
everyone says what did I say everyone
says they want everyone wants what they
say they don't want I'll think about
that another episode and I'll have the
feeling and I'll know what it is to talk
about but anyway [__] sorry I trailed
off there how about this [__] how
about Logan how about this Logan Paul
thing dude hey you know what hey Logan
Paul dude that was really noble of you
to take three weeks off he made a video
called the return and he's like climbing
out of rocks all dirty that's like
they're returning us all this grand
music and [__] and he's just like I'm
back [__] he's he has a video
called the return like he went away to
do something Noble he's like I'm back I
took a hiatus sorry everyone
no you filmed someone who hung
themselves hung themselves dude oh dude
you took oh you took
three weeks off oh dude you're such a
good person man you're still a [__]
dumb [__] dude any-any it did and how
about he commented on cardi B [__] weird
cardi B is like they're trying to
crucify crucify me like Christ and he
wrote Lal you're telling me hey man
you're not sorry
oh you donated a million dollars to a
[__] charity that deals with suicide
prevention cool man you should have done
that you're still an [__]
money doesn't change who you are when
people you know it's like I know we know
this but money doesn't change who you
are
say good night Gracie
you deserve an ultimate slam you deserve
that Grand Slam I mean come on dude what
was his [__] guy thinking he's not 12
you're 23 or something oh you're back
and all these [__] 12 year olds are
just like he's back coming and [__]
he's back mommy no you can't watch it
yeah but I want to see him yeah but
remember how sad you got when he filmed
someone no I don't remember anything
longer than six seconds who are you
what's that mom I [__] then she
starts to clean up the pants mara what
are you doing you [__] yourself I did
yeah I remember we're early member six
seconds I'm a goldfish hey mom what what
huh you said what no you said hey mom
oh don't remember can't watch Logan
Powell sorry I said
let me clean it up clean what up your
[__] what [__] look at your pants ill
then he looks away for a little bit and
then he says why does that smell like
[__]
that's logan paul's fan base say yeah
alright i talked about her so much but
like that return video like come on dude
you're not christ you're a guy named
Logan you know you got two first names
you [__] logan paul you got two first
names hey man you got two first names
can't trust a guy with two first names
it's weird right Todd it would be great
if somebody's name was like Tom bill
it's always like my buddy Aaron Aaron
Paul's like that I trust him he's a good
guy but Oh Tom bill that's your name bro
what's another one that's not a last
name Steve Vinnie Steve that's it like
that's how dumb it is get a real last
name like [__] buttersworth or
Smithers or [__] if you don't I mean
anything anything that's like what
what's that I never heard that one
before
Oswalt that's a good one Patton Oswalt's
got a good last name oh this probably
middle name or some [__]
so but this is by the way we're
recording this on Sunday it's Super Bowl
Sunday and I'm doing it during the game
cuz [__] it
Oh two teams are playing cool two teams
are playing yeah I'm 37 if you're on a
team and you're over [__] 22 you're
out take it off being individual all
unless you're making a lot of money
doing it then it's okay
cuz then you're making money Tom Brady
can graduate the [__] lesions got the
best life cool got the supermodel wife
nice got beautiful children's great you
gotta [__] put on a uniform to go
make millions and millions of dollars do
it you won you got precision QB great
doing but you 30 you put on shorts in
the top to go play at the park and other
people are wearing the shorts in the top
so yeah anyway yeah so I don't you know
Super Bowl Sunday is when we're
recording this so I don't know who won
but also why did you know is I don't
give a [__] who wins I'm not gonna watch
it because it's now and you know fine
watch it and [__] but like when people
are yelling at the TV anytime someone's
yelling at the TV I gotta leave the room
it's a TV not a judge you know how about
when that girl was like you know what
it's my honor it's my honor to lock you
up Larry Nasser that's the guys name
Larry Nasser it's my honor she almost
got the case thrown out because she was
just like can't wait can't wait to see a
rotten prison you [__] Oh can't wait I
hope guys [__] in the butt you say you
know how it feels see a [__] oh gunk
with the gavel could could she look more
like she works that [__] in TGI Fridays
hey real quick could judge
what's-her-name aqua aqua aqua Leena ah
cool he's superhero hi I'm Judge Aqua
Lina a van
sure of pedophiles okay hey judge aqua
Lina dude could you look like you work
at TGI Fridays little bit more hey judge
a Kalina good job locking him up but
real quick
bring me some mozzarella sticks dude
thanks for putting him away for 7,000
years even though it doesn't matter that
you know I you know what but it always
bugged me when they're like you will
serve three life sentences back to back
hey can't you gonna leave them in there
after he dies nah can't one life
sentence that's all that's it that's the
most that's it what are we [__] cats
nah you live once
oh man
Natalie Portman were a judge Aquilino
[__] shirt I'm Sara alive oh good
gunk come on man I wish I was on that
episode of SNL I was standing next to
her and I would have a shirt that says
looks like she works at TGI Fridays that
would be ultimate slam dude I'm all
about slams man I am the son of the
queen of the slam and I am all about
slams man you called me Grand Slam dude
and my [__] Darrell strawberry one
time first met game I ever went to first
baseball game I ever went to bases got
loaded
Darryl Strawberry hit a grand slam
everyone screamed jumped up I was
[__] like six and I cried immediately
cuz everyone dude maybe that's where it
comes from
maybe that's why I hate when people
scream at the TV because that was
harrowing man I'm six years old my dad
took me to a met game I don't know
what's going on I'm eating a [__] hot
dog and I'm with my grandfather my
grandpa BAM
it's Italian and my dad and my uncle
Vinny and dalian and Darryl Strawberry
how'd it get that last name hit a grand
slam everyone [__] jumps up my popcorn
and hot dog go
flying and I start crying hard
immediately cuz I'm six there's my first
baseball game
that's my origin story now I am a slam
master dude and if I see some [__] dude
on SNL I would [__] do that a hundred
percent but Judge oculina definitely
looks like she works at TGI Fridays and
that's what's up and you can't you know
what you can say whatever you want you
can say how great of a person she is and
that's great but she does look like that
and you goddamn know it go ahead be
offended but she does goddamn look like
that so my whole thing is sure give him
seven sentences back to back but before
you do that and before you get a little
too passionate about it because you're a
judge so don't be that passionate just
send them away before you do all that
you mind passing me some mozzarella
sticks do you mind
refilling my mr. Pibb
people love to [__] be good man
people love to be good online and in
front of people be good by yourself in
your [__] house be good by yourself
in your [__] house donate to charity
don't tell anybody
give a guy a ride home tell no one don't
give a guy a ride home and then [__]
tell everyone you gave a guy a ride home
then you secret piece of [__] what the
[__] is that dude
oh I'm angry one fire just pulled up a
[__] something called a snack stadium
you guessed it it's a [__] dumbass
tray that looks like a football stadium
and it's got different things in each
[__] compartment and field goals if I
went to a party and saw that I'd [__] on
it I'd piss on and piss and [__] on it
and they'd be like what are you doing
you're ruining the snack stadium and I'd
be like don't say that oh [__] don't
call it that I'm pissing
some guy commented why is there only one
dip MNC yeah keep the [__] look it
you know what I don't like about it is
they put all different snacks in all the
different compartments I was like how
many of the compartments are there
thirty and not quite almost and there's
there's some things that should even be
in there and the only reason that
they're in there is because there's
enough there's too many compartments
like [__] that [__] don't heart it up
when it should be functional dude [__]
you dude you gonna put Mike and Ikes in
up whoever ate a Mike and Ike whoever
ate a [__] what was the one that had
good in it good & plenty dude whoever
ate a good and plenty
those are so bad dude I had one good &
plenty once it ruined my [__] year
that white and purple [__] why is it
minty or some I don't even know what it
is I just remembered it was
it was awful judge oculina
I sentence you to eat good and plenties
and Mike and Ikes every day
Mike and Ike you know good and plenties
though are the worst good & plenty Mike
and Ikes are fine now that I'm looking
at my mermen room they're not that bad
good and plenty uh what's up with the
[__] why is this snack after why can't
it anything that's a snack
why can't it have the word and they in
it why is it got to be cute I want to
make a snap snack and I want to call it
you know
say I come out with a snack and and the
guy's name is [__] Tim Chris and
Tim's that's what they are and if you
say Chris and Tim's you don't get any I
sentence you to [__] four life
sentences back to back did that bugs me
man you will be serving four hundred and
seventy five years in jail that's five
consecutive couldn't think of the word
idiot consecutive life sentences oh yeah
four hundred seventy-five years cool
what the [__] is as altered carbon net
this altered carbon nah do you guys
watch all the carbon on Netflix I
watched two episodes and I don't know
what I'm doing
I don't get it I'm an idiot there's so
much did everyone in that show so like
talking so much and I'm just a [__]
great premise though I feel like it's
one of those shows in Episode five I'll
be like okay I get it and I mean I love
that actor Joel Kinnaman he's so dope
he's one of those guys that all guys
like I don't know what it is
he said The Laugh Factory once I saw him
and I introduced myself
he probably easily like who's this
[__] homeless guy but he's cool and
he's jacked in that [__] show he's
up dude that's a good lastname Kinnaman
what if his name was [__] Joel Paul
you know it wouldn't be as cool he looks
like a chick I did it once too you know
what's funny is uh sometimes when guys
are real hot they make hot chicks
I just come out of closet but it's true
though guys also have killer chick legs
you ever seen a [__] [__] with like
guy legs or hottest [__] as chick legs
they look good and dresses bro I don't
give a [__] what you think man uh
they're not thick they'll like chicks
you know you get that thick thi si si
I'm so sick of that [__] yeah she thick
let's look at these [__] Twitter
questions huh we're looking at Twitter
questions baby looking at these Twitter
questions baby I don't understand why
this is a question to be honest um what
do you care about more the Super Bowl or
Kylie Jenner having her video because
she's having a baby
is Kylie the one Kendall Kylie's the one
with all the surgery right yeah man you
could buy that huh I don't care about
either both I probably care about the
Super Bowl a little more or I guess I
could say I care about college under
having a baby less that's from Glenn T Y
Wagner at childish Glenn be know well he
said I know change it in you're damn
right bro
yeah I don't care about any of that [__]
I don't care if anyone's having a baby
my mom will say [__] like you know do
you know Lauren bigglesworth and I'm
like what you went to school with her oh
yeah yeah her dad died and she's
pregnant
that's what my mom's tells me who died
and who's pregnant her dad died died on
her wedding day and she's pregnant
it's always about weddings death and
more babies do you know Lisa uh Paul no
you went to her you went to school with
her anyway she got married and then got
pregnant and then everybody died oh yeah
yeah you know her you should send or
something who is that you remember no Oh
fine I'll just go [__] never talking
ever again that's something that girls
do Oh fine I just won't ever say
anything ever again in the world then uh
here's another one just saw a guy pull
out a brown leather wallet from his
brown leather jacket he looked in it
like he was searching for a [__] and it
made me throw up a little bit all right
man well Jeff what's his name at mr.
jeffing ttan that's I mean just saw a
guy pull out a brown leather wallet from
his brown leather jacket well he see
matches you know does he have blond hair
got to have blond hair if he got yeah
he's got no is it no yeah got blond hair
if you have a [__] brown leather
jacket also there's this thing going
around the women is doing a yoga pose
and her baby is sucking her tit
I guess she's feeding her I go right
side up and let her feed you know like
uh you do a naked yoga and yoga and you
may be sucking on your tit
I guess she's killing two birds with one
stone right I'm a busy mom look I'm a
busy mom I need to do yoga and I need to
feed my baby so I'm gonna go upside-down
suck my tit come get some food
yeah hope she does a lot there's a bunch
of pictures like that with her I feel
like I've seen it before
no I don't know I don't know if I have a
[__] up in - okay
should we do the elder that we're
talking about okay I'm gonna do an elder
this week and we haven't announced one
in a while
and it's because I I haven't noticed any
one really going above and beyond you
know the to spread the word of the cult
and our numbers are you know I wouldn't
say they plateaued but they're they've
been holding so I'm not threatening you
guys or holding this over your head but
like you know you get to be an elder if
you um if you do that and if you help
and if you get other friends on board I
mean dude you know we're we're the we're
the new you know we're not a religion
we're a cult so we're trying to spread
the word and you can be accepted into
the congratulations cult if you're a
true baby and you become an elder if you
[__] go beyond and you do the work
and if you don't you're not gonna become
an elder I don't know what else to tell
you you know I don't know what's again
it's like you know this person I'm going
to announce as an elder is honestly one
of the reasons why is because he is a
huge fan of mine and besides the fact
that he obviously probably listens to
this podcast every single time it drops
he is honestly I've noticed through the
years a huge fan of Chris D'Elia and I
can tell because I influenced him and I
can tell because he a lot of times comes
to me for advice I know this person and
he says you know what do I do you know
he's a little older than me oh he's a
lot older than me he doesn't you know
he's like what I do in my career how do
I get back on top you know I've helped
this man he's a good guy and he listens
to me and it's helped him in many ways
he's kind of had a resurgence in his
career and I want to besides
you know I don't want to say you're
welcome because that's kind of pompous
so I want to give him this pin of
eldership and this certificate from
congratulations his name is Bryan Callen
and we're going to send him this at
Bryan Callen you can congratulate
congratulate him he is now an elder for
the congratulations podcast for always
being a true baby and for absolutely
listening to daddy because I'm his daddy
and he is my son and this is for Bryan
Callen this right here this this pin so
go look up Bryan Callen if you don't
know who he is you might not but he's
gonna die soon
cuz he's [__] almost 60 and go
congratulate him and we'll DM you with
the details Bryan that's about it on
this episode of congratulations
now don't hate guys by the way that was
a secret slam you know I know I mean it
he's an elder you know what's going on
[__] clean it son of the squint of the
slam is struck again listen the son of
this queen of the slam there's drunk
again
hey Darryl Strawberry oh I think I see
your Grand Slam and I raise you one okay
so um square cats have you guys switched
yet download the free square cash app
and to reward codes into rewards code
congrats and get $5 give $5 to the times
up dot-com well who wrote this one fire
download the free square cash app into
rewards code Congrats get $5 and give $5
- times up get it for iOS or Android now
and I have my new tour being announced
very soon in about a week and about a
week I'm announcing my new tour the
first leg of my new tour I'm gonna hit
some cities but I'm hit a lot of the
cities you guys can tell me where you
want me to combat
I'm gonna get to him I'm doing a lot of
East Coast ones on the fall just so you
know the Winnipeg Calgary Saskatchewan
I'm coming this week Cleveland I'm
coming in if I'm coming in a few weeks
absque Ribe to the youtube channel
spread this word man I am NOT gonna keep
doing this if you don't if it doesn't
get bigger I'm not gonna keep doing it
it needs to build and build and build
otherwise I'm done
download the Chris D'Elia app you see
some behind the scenes of this and you
see all some other stuff go to they go
to the App Store and type in my name and
new videos go up Tuesday's or Wednesdays
man on fire are incorrigible watch that
and thanks for listening guys by the way
I have a movie up coming out called half
magic and another one coming out called
life in a year so be on the lookout for
that I'm on oh and I'm on alone together
this week oh you know what I'm actually
I'm on the good doctor on Monday night
and their mom alone together on
Wednesday night you guys are the best
thank you so much for helping me spread
the word if you have to all you elders
out there I'm keeping you in mind and
remember in Kuta say good night
[Music]